Oooookaaaayyyyy....
Hello Everybody my Name is Markiplier and Welcome to I woke up to you again.Oh my god, you are very loud
We're back to normal. Okay, so this Is not a horror game as far as I know.
This is a game about waking up next to someone after a
not so one-night stand, as far as I know. I woke up
Yeah, I did and then what happened? Hello?
Dot dot dot dot. I woke up next to her or him? Let's say her for the sake of argument.
I moved to a new place recently, and found someone.
Ahh
I woke up next to her again. She told me "Hey this is a one-time thing.
I have this and that," and I said "Yeah, of course, me too. Yet here we are."
"Hi! " "That was Pretty good. " No. (starts to laugh) "You- you -you should get going."
Excuse you! What are you.... Hi, how's it goin'?
Hello! Hey
Look
It's been great and all but it'd be best for the both of us, if we kept this a two-night stand.
I completely agree!
30 minute stand, you mean
Uhhh
Sure yeah , okay , all right.
Well that's what we agreed to, sure.
No time for that "it's complicated stuff".  Hey, great idea
I'll add you on Facebook and put our status as "it's complicated".
Heh, just kidd- Ja, JK!
Not really, cuz that would be making it more than a two-night stand
Uh oh...
Ugh, i'm gonna be Late
Where are my pants? I dunno! On the floor?
"They're on my dresser", "They magically disappeared", "Thrown out the window".
Well I don't know which one of these is true!
Can any of them be true? They've magically disappeared!
Magically...
They're all my dresser I- maybe....
Your pants are on my dresser. Thanks! I'd sad- I'd say see you but  well, Goodbye.
See ya! See ya!
I kept meeting her after that. Not on purpose
We just seemed to be in the right place at the right time
She'd say something like "What a coincidence! Nice to see you again" and I'd reply
(laughs) "I've-I've gotta go" Imma reply I gotta go I gotta get a-
"Want to grab a drink?"
Want to come over to my place? Wanna come over to  my place? Grab a drink come over to my-
(voice gets higher) Wanna come over to my place?
Yeah, want to come over to my place?
She was charming. I never could refuse, I feel so tired afterwards. It doesn't feel good anymore.
But we still do it.
Morning! I've been thinking...
I'm ready to make a commitment to our relationship of repeated One-Night stands
Hahaha what about you? Me too! Sure! All right me too.
I'm ready for this relationship to level up.
Awesome! So, there's a gap in my phone contacts just waiting to be filled.
Want to fill it?
Here's- Nooooo. Nohoho
I don't care if that sounds like a euphemism, I'm not about that!
Here's- here's my number! *fart noise*
Yeah there you go. Call me! I'm open between 10 and 9.
What, no midnight shifts?
(laughs) A face like this requires work.
A face like this requires a LOT of work. You don't even understand that much work
Got to get my beauty sleep on
As much as i've gotten tired of it all, i can't let go.
It's a habit I'm not willing to break. I think... they call that a relationship...
After that, everything began to remind me of her. If she wasn't there I felt aimless, restless.
(female singing)
I forgot what I'd been doing. My hopes, my ambitions before I met her
One day I wake up feeling sluggish, head pounding.
I've never felt like this before
I automatically turn to call her, I know she'll make it better or will she make it worse?
Of course not
What is she, a virus?
I'll call her, sure. "Hey I need you to please come over."
Know what, I don't need her. I just want her to be here. Why would-
SoOo. This is weird, this is weird.
Years pass. I can't remember much.
I can't remember my friends, my family
They'll talk, but I won't listen. All I remember is... Her.
What the hell happened! What?!
(Voice gets higher) What the hell happened?! Did she consume my brain? Is my brain done gone drip out my ears?
What the fuck happened?!
I was just having a lovely relationship as far as I could tell!
The fuck happened??!
(voice gets even higher) Where did my life go!? What happened to my voice?
Okay, well that was weird. (laughs) So apparently she's like some emotion vampire.
She's gonna suck the emotions out of me if you know what I mean.
I wake up next to him.... this time
Go with him. I moved to a new place recently and found someone
Hey, how's it goin'? I woke up next to him again.
He told me "Hey this is a One-Time thing, I have this and that".
And I said yeah, of course. Me too
Yet here we are
Are you... Are you an emotional vampire?
You gonna suck the emotions outta me?
You should get going. (laughs) Get out, Get- You should get going.
Yeah, just one thing
It's been great and all, but it'd be best for the both of us if we kept this a two-night stand.
That's what I'm saying!
I said exactly that!
Thirty-minute stand you mean. Ha yeah. Ha, we lasted longer than that.
Well I did. Someone else didn't.
Oh I really got to go. Where'd I put my pants?
I'd say see you but... goodbye
Alright, goodbye. BYE, BYE
Just guud - BYE
I kept meeting him after that, not on purpose.
We just seemed to be at the right place at the right time. He'd say something like-
"What a coincidence! Nice to see you again."
And I'd reply "Fuck off! I gotta, I gotta go! I got I gotta go. Yeah, well I gotta go.
Gotta goo...
Maybe a bit blunt, but there was something off about him.
So I stopped anything from developing, before it was too late
(quietly) Dun dun dun
Well ALRIGHT! Alright, well that's that then!
Say goodbye to the emotion vampire and off you go!
Ok, there's another mystery here. I'm not getting the answer of why this is happening at all in the first place.
You know what I mean?
Who is this Person and why--
Are they sucking the emotions out of me? Why do I become so dependent?
She told me "Hey this is a one time thing I have this and that." and I said "yeah of course, me too."
Yet here we are.
"That was pretty good" Yeah,  you- you.. You think that was pretty good, yeah.
Hah. Feeling's mutual
Look. It's been great and all, but it'd be best for both of us if we kept this a two-night stand.
Okay. Let's see. Will we see each other again?
Maybe. I like you I just, oh hey, whoa, hey, whoa! We got a lot of Jitters,  we've been infected!
Look. I really got to go, maybe we'll see each other around the city.
Maybe we will, maybe we- Want to stay for breakfast?
Want to stay for BreAkFasT?!
I've been told I'm a great cook.. argh..  Let's go. I can't deny free food
Well all right. I cooked us breakfast, conversation wasn't as awkward as I thought it'd be.
I wouldn't mind having it again. I didn't tell her that
Okay, see then. She left. I kept meeting her after that, not on purpose.
We seemed to just be in the right place at the right time.
She'd say something like "What a coincidence! Nice to see you again."
Oh my god. I've already read all this. I'd reply-
"Wanna grab a drink?"
Same! Want to grab a drink?
What about me?
I don't know... I dunno
"Do you think this is bad for us?" "What, of course not!"
If it makes you feel good, take a little- takes a little off the edge doesn't it?
Nah. It's too much! Too much, that's what it is. It's too much
It's too frequent
What? No...
Yeah. What about we go for another round? Just forget it all! Forget these worries.
I can't! You'll-you'll make me forget all my friends, that I didn't really have that many of in the first place.
No, I don't want to. I can't. Then maybe, we can just talk.
We don't have to do anything. I just... don't want to loose contact with you, is all.
I CAN'T GIVE IN! I WON'T GIVE IN
Why are you fighting instinct? I don't know. I keep fighting, ah! I stood my ground
I feared what would happen if I didn't. Ah ahh
And then she exploded Into a ball of light! After that, I refused to think about her and she just... left.
I never saw her again
Every night it doesn't happen, I feel strange. As if I'm missing something, a crucial part of myself.
But as time goes on, I forget. I don't mind as much, my mind clears.
Weird... Oh, hi! A good friend moved in with me Yesterday
How have you, been? What-what is this?
Have you-
How have you been?!
How've you been?!
Greaat...
Normal, bored in fact.
It'll be nice to have you around again. You too.
So what are you up to? Haven't heard from you in a long time.  (laughs) Yeah, Whooopsies
I've just been busy with this girl.
Ooh, tell me more! Can I meet her?
Nope, nope! Evade the- Imma show you a picture.  I don't know what this is  gonna do. But i'm gonna show it
Here's a picture
No, she'll become infected too!!!
Alright, whatever.
Here uh, let me show you. Need to find it on my phone. See this pic? Isn't it cute?
There's-There's nothing there. It's only you.
Is everything fine?
I hate it when people worry for me. Sometimes though, I wonder what might happen if I told the truth.
I'm not suuree...
I'm not sure.
Not sure. Something's happened. Hey i'm here for you.
I'm not gonna leave again if you need me. Yeah...
Is everything fine? Who, was that girl?
I care about you , you know?
Thanks. Hey, you don't look so good.
I try not to remember our time together. Sometimes I remember vividly. Everything comes Back
What's happening? Why am I here again?
I'm tired once more. Sluggish,  slow thoughts
More tired than I have ever been before.
But I have my good friend here now. To help me let the past go, prevent  me from meeting up one last time.
OKAY!?
Again, still CONFUSED?!
I don't understand! Well I kind of understand. So is this girl made up? Or is this girl....
....
(voice gets high) Is there something about this (laughs)  that I'm not seein'?
So who's this friend that moved in?
This "real" friend, that don't look so good sometimes.
I'm not sure I fully understand exactly what's happening here.
But maybe you guys have a better handle on it.
Maybe there's more endings here?
I mean obviously there are multiple endings, but it doesn't have a count of what end- what endings are where.
You know what I mean?
So like,  wha-  like ahughauh!
I don't know. But either way, that is I Woke Up Next To You
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you think the story is all about down in the comments below
If you want to play this game for yourself and try to find other endings
I'll put the link in the description
Thanks again everybody and as always I will see you in the next video! Buh-bye!